for home carer rachel her car is
literally a lifeline her clients depend
on it but keeping on the road is getting
more and more difficult
it's definitely something i've noticed i
filled up only yesterday and it was 77
pound for a whole tank of fuel i can
remember a couple of years back where it
was just 35 pounds for a tank of fuel so
obviously when you're driving your car
you know 300 miles a week and to visit
clients and go and support them in their
own homes you know that all really adds
up and it's quite a lot of miles
rachel's company has had to increase
mileage rates it pays
it's just one sector feeling the strain
as the cost of filling an average family
car rose to a hundred pounds this week
is it getting ridiculous yes it is
getting ridiculous you know with
everybody you know for everybody what
with the rising cost of everything else
as well
it's just a nightmare now you know a lot
of the people i've heard stories from
have been paying to go to work
it used to cost me around 50 60 pounds
for this car and i was about 90 95
pounds four by riding my bike and
everything to work everything which is
an option
new data reveals one in 20 workers say
they wouldn't be able to cover their
living costs for even one week if they
lost their main source of income leading
to many changing how they're getting
around
the number of people taking the bus at
least once a week rose from 12 to the
start of march to 15
by the end of may an extra 1 million
passengers and in the last three months
the number of people cycling has climbed
steeply up 200 percent on certain days
compared to march 2020
in the centre of town the
gloucestershire bike project says it's
seeing more and more people switching
from four wheels to two
it runs projects to donate bikes to
those on the lowest incomes what we have
seen this year and particularly in the
last three months we're getting probably
four or five times the number of
requests that we used to get and we get
a lot of requests anyway you know we
donate hundreds of bikes every year
but the people we're getting them from
we're seeing more people that are in
work on low incomes than we are people
that are out of work on very low incomes
whether it's bikes or buses record
prices at the pumps are having an impact
on how we all get around affordably dan
whitehead sky news in gloucester